hallo leute wir sind heute in den
niederlanden genau genommen in entkommen
und allem auf das ist arthur er arbeitet
hier an der saxion university und wir
werden heute über unterschiede zwischen
den niederlanden und deutschland
sprechen
los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
menasse das ist ja für mich schon als
erster mensch ist die rolltreppe ist
ewald kreuzer die farben neongelb farben
bunte sowie würmer in holland
es könnte sein dass es auch moderne uni
gebäude in deutschland gibt die ähnlich
aussehen
aber generell erkennt man sofort der
unterschied wenn man von deutschland
lisa land fährt an den knalligen farben
ich wollte viel entdecken musiker
technologie wenn man gleich
wahrscheinlich auch gehören dass ihr
hatte mit der kerb ist ein studien danke
heißt textil und der sehr populär
bewahre deutschen stränden denn so was
gibt es in deutschland gar nicht ansieht
haben die leute die neuen also wenn ihr
wollt kommen auch reingehen ich hab da
gerade sogar einen deutschen gesehen der
auch gerade was am lift warum bist du
wohnst du dich in den niederlanden
michael wichtig dass internationales
studieren also grundsätzlich auch im
ausland weil ich denke auch wenn man ihn
studiert die wir zum beispiel flexible
zeiten die internationale branche und
sollte dementsprechend ausgewiesen oder
englisch sprechen ja jetzt sind wir im
labor weil jamie du kommst auch aus
deutschland und arbeitet hier genau ich
habe hier studiert
wenn jetzt vor vier jahren bin ich
angefangen habe habe ich angefangen hier
zur arbeit arbeite mittlerweile in dem
studiengang passion text technology also
drei tage die woche als dozentin und
zwei tage die woche als wegweiser wie
lange lebte schon in den niederlanden
feuerwehr und was ist der größte
unterschied zwischen den niederlanden
und deutschland
das essen definitiv vermittelt werden ja
auf jeden fall die holländer x factor
ist also kroketten alles auflösen und
das wirklich auch in essen vermittelt
wir vermehrt sich das virus vermitteln
ich mag eigentlich auch viele sachen
hier muss ich ganz ezb diese direktheit
länger dass die alles ein bisschen
ruhiger gelassen wir deutschen ja immer
alles sofort machen lassen und so weiter
ist der normale einfach so beiseite den
rohrbruch hast dann braucht man zwei
tage warten aber auf anderen seite sehr
praktisch dass wir ein bisschen
entspannt fassen
also ich finds halt alles die lockere
also die menschen sind alle total offen
die deutschen auch offen aber seid so
man wird ihn schon mit offenen armen
empfangen empfang für mich ja und das
merkt man halt auch alles ein bisschen
in deutschland aufzeigen sowie auf
abstand und hier seit mehr zum beispiel
man geht in die dozenten wenn man für
den zu setzen möchte dann rennt man halt
einfach rein und spricht die dozenten
auch wie du an mich darauf ich bin halt
auch noch nicht so alte regierung sich
auch einfach genug
jan er war doch so kultur aber ein
deutschland ist das halt nicht so in
deutschland darf man halt er immer sie
ich würde sagen dass diese ja immer sehr
ruhig und relaxed und wie man das auch
bekennt und genau wir sind halt oft
immer so wirklich okay wir müssen alles
genau machen und die niederländer sind
ja auch sehr lecker aber gerade die uni
ist nicht so organisiert wie man von
deutschland kennt also man muss
irgendwelche unterlagen länger warten
oder wenn mal eine deadline
überschritten wird es eigentlich auch
kein problem
dieses organisierte der deutschen die
niederländer sind wer viel lockerer sehr
viel offener das ist meistens sehr schön
sehr angenehm
die sind dann aber auch sehr viel
direkter da muss man einfach nicht
umgehen können wenn man etwas falsch
macht oder wenn es zu beachten gibt
lagen hier auch ganz unverblümt heraus
dann muss man halt mal gern wendung zu
geben dann auch sehr witzig recht viele
leute immer sagen typisch deutsch dass
die deutschen so direkt nennt und das
ist passiert an einem deutschen ja eher
selten dass man jemand trifft dennoch
direkt studieren medienbereich und wenn
ich dann irgendwelche design waffen
abgeben muss irgendwie waren weil sowas
dann sagen die ganz genau aufpassen dass
wir nicht nur aber ganz recht unverblümt
und aus deutschland kennt man ja das ist
dann immer so ein bisschen er und schien
das wird auch gesagt und so aber die
sind ein bisschen zurückhaltend
netter dann geht's mal stark ich glaube
der größte unterschied betrifft
niederländern und mehr raum für den witz
an der sache mit dem haken oder als den
spaß wenn ich also in deutschland die
schule gearbeitet alles immer todernst
aber der spaß befreit genau also nicht
immer mehr zwischen die deutschen auch
lassen aber gehört deutschland wenn das
noch ein job geht es gut wenn ich glaube
es gibt unterschiede zwischen der art
und weise wie holländer arbeiten und
deutsche weil die deutschland sehr oft
sehr seriös sind und das alles ziemlich
genau nehmen und die holländer sind ein
bisschen getötet
da würden wir es erst ein fall natürlich
kann man das hier ist in die mine
handelt
hier sehen alle um die räume aussieht
und hipster coworking space und aber wir
sind auch in der kreativen erkennung
nach unseren technik medienformat die
kommunikative sieht nicht so aus aber
sie beim modell aus aber wirklich so
dieses was du gerade ansprechend
hauptwerke wie versprochen ist war die
gekämpft bestimmt ein fall
deutsch-niederländische geschichten
was ist für dich typisch deutschland
typisch deutsch ist man mitten in die
nacht in 3d ampel abrutschte
du bist zu fuß dass du wartet bis ein
gericht auch für also machen wir das in
deutschland keine da aber wir warten
und wie macht ihr das wir gehen einfach
und gibt es etwas was in den
niederlanden vermisst an deutschland
quasi das essen also das brot ist hier
gar nicht meinte ich mag wer gerne
vollkorn sehr viele alles mit gemüse und
so was auch darin irgendwie und hier ist
alles er sehr viel
er wurde für april kursniveau schön an
was ich auch sollte deutschland vor mit
brötchen deutsche brot und brötchen ja
tatsächlich
deutsches brot gibt es etwas was in den
niederlanden vermisst hier an
deutschland dann hat er darüber gehen
wir auch genau ich habe auch einen meter
langen deutschland studiert und erwarten
die mensa total perfekte und das hat man
hier leider nicht vorhabe hierfür ein
bisschen teurer mit dem essen und auch
nicht so lecker finden dürfen monate was
gibt's denn dann jeder mensch handel
er wäre viel zitierte sehr viel fettiges
gesund leben geht nicht so gut wenn man
hier in der uni ist und jetzt zeigen wir
euch mal ein typisch holländisches groß
kann man den einst zusammen quetschen
also das ist jetzt so typisch
niederländisch typischer geht nicht mehr
und zwar ist das eine art wie nennt man
hat einfach ihr automatischer also bei
uns in deutschland gibt es auch
automaten
da sind andere snacks dieses schiff oder
gummibärchen
aber hier diktiert das aus meistens wenn
man da drüben herkommt das sind die
ganzen waffen greifen wenn man ein paar
wiederum schmeckt oder sage ich dann gut
zu fördern
frische art uhr naja ohne bekommen wir
hier original man schweizer war hier ein
und machte auf dazu eine form von dem
lernen
ich war vorher auch was typisch
holländisch arbeit der waren und warum
so viele deutsche nach holland fahren
sind natürlich die coffeeshops denn in
holland ist kirchen legal und in
deutschland legal als deutsche in den
niederlanden ein geschäft eröffnet wie
bis zu werkzeuge kommen ich bin ein
stück gekommen von studio 5 studium an
der hochschule hat der bildhauer
studiert für vier jahre insgesamt
gelernt wenn hängen geblieben ich habe
ganz langsam gedanken habe mein eigenes
geschäft eröffnen
lange kann man sich das dann entwickelt
was ist denn dein geschäfte ein geschäft
ist die erste salatbar von effizienz
salatbars also hier wären wir ganz schon
gelernt die leute hier in holland die
essen ja unglaublich game city dessen
wie kommt denn deine salatbar an
also wenn man so ein bisschen weiter weg
guckt als ins studio sichtung westen
dann sieht man solche geschäfte schon
unglaublich viel gelaufen richtig gut
stimmt das dass die holländer aus
deutscher perspektive eher ungesund
essen
ich glaube das ist mehr sein vorurteil
also sie haben keine friedhöfe zu haben
würde aus erwitte zufrieden mit unseren
tag ich bin sehr zufrieden
hast du uns alles gezeigt nicht alles
aber alle freue ich mich heute zeigen
konnte habe ich euch gezeigt und hat
spaß gemacht
dann kommen wir noch mal wieder wenn ihr
auch mal nach holland fahren wollt
besucht entweder eine der schönsten
städte von holland wenn ihr lust habt
noch übungen zu machen und das vokabular
von dieser episode zu lernen dann könnt
ihr einfach einen petschel werden zum
beispiel hier und natürlich mit unseren
kanal abonnieren zum beispiel hier danke
für zu schauen und mit bald so do i do i